all right let's take another
call what up Theo this is
Hunter um I'm just calling I've got a
bit of a dilemma right now do tail
brother onward uh recently you know I
was making out with this
girl
and we was we was making out for
probably you know one one minute and I
just busted a nut right there oh yeah
and I don't know what to do so I was
just calling
to kind of get your guidance on that and
you know I'm just just don't really know
what to do oh yeah buddy well
look that's just some nut homie that's
all you know there's nothing you're not
a bad guy you don't need to be scared or
nothing you're doing fine
um I think you might you know who know
if you if you were only making out you
might have a damn your pH balance might
be off or something you might have be
you know be like a plus six or something
you you know you might want to get your
damn levels checked or something or at
least have somebody do that on
you while you look at a nudie mag or
something you know
because you know you want to make sure
you're not
just vibrating so much if you get around
a you know a nipple that you're just
uh you're just sprouting and creaming
all the time for no reason you know just
sprouting and creaming you know for just
you know you don't want somebody to flip
on a light switch in a distance and you
[__]
just just [__] put your own eye out
with that with that bust homie that
[__] bust but yeah you're doing fine
buddy
I think yeah you your your levels might
be up or down or something you might not
have you might uh could have been
something you
ate you know if sometimes if I have some
um what are they call like zesty little
like uh
little um piece it's like a green bean
but it's [__] it's for violence you
know it's like
um uh peppers like a uh red peppers you
know I'll shoot a robin off off fence
you know if I if I start popping off
after that but um you're probably going
to be fine buddy and it's okay I think
God just wants to warn you says hey
buddy you're going to be
really you know you're going to be on
the front lines for us because you like
to
shoot and just be
careful so and second of all I'm proud
of you man I'm proud of you for
ejaculating you know too many men feel
ashamed when they eat Jack or whatever
and you out here busting and creaming
and creaming and busting over there with
your lady and it's that time of year too
it's winter dude if you
can't if you ain't coming in the winter
buddy what are you
doing you know I don't think you know
that's a winter sport buddy so you out
there just uh just stirring your own
eggs buddy do your [__] Daddy get out
there and [__] get your [__] boy bust
out homie young
killer but uh yeah brother I love you
man and yeah you might just have that
that extra energy in you you you ever
see somebody that rub their feet on the
carpet and then they come up and [__]
zap you like that that might be you boy
you might just have you might just your
your pH balance might be a little high
so we want to get that [__] checked out
buddy or have somebody take your pulse
while you Jer off you know and see what
happens to you buddy you're doing good
though love you Daddy Merry
Christmas bells will be
ringing